foreign
Town H-Town gostros and talk to the
Mighty Joe what's up Joe
hi Dr John what up pleasure to speak
with you it's a pleasure to speak with
you man hey Art
are our boys gonna pull it out or what
oh I believe so I think they're gonna
make one last trade here at the end and
I think we're gonna pull it over the top
ah dude that's my Joe I'm in man I'm in
all right so what's up
yeah man I've I've listened to countless
hours of your show and uh man you've
helped me you've helped me a ton and so
I just want to say thank you for that
first off
um my question is
um
you've talked about emotional infidelity
and you talked about emotional abuse
and I'm I'm wanting to understand if
if my wife is emotionally
um
has emotional infidelity and if she's
abusive or neglectful or if I'm just um
being too sensitive and needy because
that's basically what she's told me
there's a lot of layers here already man
so so let me know what's going on
yeah so the backstory
um you know I met my wife
um through
um actually her cousin uh we worked
together she introduced me to my wife
now and
um you know everything was great in the
beginning
um I thought she was a wonderful person
um she was a wonderful person and she
was a I thought she had a wonderful
heart she's a teacher just like your
wife is
um and she really really loved kids and
that was one of her big things that she
really really wanted to have kids so we
got married and
um we immediately tried to have kids
because I knew how important that was to
her and I wanted to have kids too and
you know I never you know thought I was
going to be ready and I don't think he
ever already just had to kind of jump
into it so
um we had kids right away I mean we when
we tried to have kids it happened very
very quickly
um but but quickly after we have had
kids
um
the our sex life just fell apart
I combined it in her you know that I
needed the intimacy and
um you know that I I felt like she was
really distant and
she basically just told me you know I'm
too tired
um I don't have time for it or there's
always an excuse
um
we we went to counseling for a bit
and
[Music]
um
during the counseling sessions it came
up
and then
for whatever reason she basically just
told the counselor that she didn't want
to continue anymore
um so it stopped
um it's gone from so wait hold on so
when you brought up
when you're talking about what are the
challenges in your relationship and you
brought up the lack of sexual intimacy
um y'all aren't sleeping together you're
not in in usually these conversations
are not just about doing it they're also
about like
you don't hold my hand you you leave the
room when I walk in like there's not
that Gentle Touch on my shoulder like so
there's a whole picture here when you
brought that up right she just said this
conversation's over I'm out
I mean it wasn't that quickly but it was
it was very relatively quickly I mean it
was brought up towards the end of one
one session and then the beginning of
another session she said she just didn't
want to continue anymore and
um another backstory with her what she's
told me about her past is she's been
married was married previously and she's
confided to me that her ex-husband was
physically abusive
um not it was like a one one time
occurrence but he was
um and you know I've always thought okay
well that has something to do with it
um and I think the counselor was trying
to see if there were some back history
there that might be another reason why
she tried to shut it down
um but the thing about this what she
told me though about her past it's
been a little confusing over the years
is you know I was very sympathetic of
what she told me and you know it broke
my heart
um but I've come to find out over the
years that she's never told anybody
about it nobody only me and she didn't
want anybody else to know about it so I
hate this I don't want to say that I
don't believe her but
initially you know I believed her 100
and then as time has gone on
I'm starting to question
whether or not
the story was 100 true or not sure that
makes sense yeah tell me about emotional
infidelity
I mean she she's very passive aggressive
um
like dismisses my feelings
um I've written I've tried multiple
different Avenues to try to get through
to her on how I feel you know I've done
the direct approach where I sit her down
and talked to her
um I've written her letters
I've written her poems
um and
it was almost
kind of like well this is I mean this is
ridiculous like you're she has told me
directly that I'm needy and too
sensitive basically what she's told me
and
she's very dismissive also of things
that are important to me yeah
um like I'll give you an example of
something small but it came up the other
day
I'm I'm really big on communication and
we obviously have a horrible Community
um communication sorry if horrible
communication or marriage and one of the
things that I've asked her to do is look
if any if she's gonna have any friends
or family come over
you know just let me know so I know in
advance they're coming
and she doesn't she hardly ever does it
and the other day
someone just popped up and I had no idea
they were coming and I asked her I said
why you know why didn't you tell me they
were coming he's like I don't need to
tell you that
so
um just just for technicality emotional
infidelity the way I would classify that
is somebody that has feelings for
somebody else
they haven't slept with them they're not
holding hands they're not going on dates
but somebody who has chosen to confide
in somebody that's not their person
they're married to so super super common
sneaks up on you
um and it can definitely be worked
through but it definitely is a thing
right that doesn't sound like what's
going on here
what sounds like what's going on here
and and I I always want to enter into
these spaces very carefully okay because
um I just want to tell for the larger
the the people listening
one of the things you never ever want to
do when somebody confides in you like
you're doing right now what you're
saying Joe is hard to say right you're
saying things out loud you're being
pretty vulnerable with me and I'm really
grateful for it that's hard for a dude
to say
hey man I'm like pouring myself out to
her and she just keeps shutting me down
it's my wife is my mother of my kids
right that's hard to say out loud right
and my guess is you don't tell a whole
bunch of people that
um but one of the Cardinal rules when
somebody opens up to you is to never bad
mouth their spouse because they might
get back together and then they're gonna
remember what you when you're like yeah
she sucks then they y'all reconcile
you're always gonna know like that dude
said my wife's you know what I mean so I
always want to tread carefully here but
I also want to be really honest and we
have a a contracted time to talk so can
I just be direct straight ahead is that
cool
sure
um
yeah you're dealing with somebody I'm
not going to diagnose her over the phone
obviously but you're dealing with
somebody who doesn't give a crap about
you
and I I need you to hear me say this
directly you're not crazy
in fact
um given what you've told me not I know
there's always two sides to every story
right and I've had these conversations
where I talked to a dude like this and I
talk to her and she's like oh yeah let
me fill you in and it's like okay that
makes sense
um
but I don't get that sense from you man
I sounds like a guy who loves his wife
and is doing everything he can to
connect with her
from the direct approach the indirect
approach the I'm going to help around
the house approach to the hey you wanna
dream together approach to hear some
poetry approach it's not like you're
doing everything you can man and you're
consuming stuff like this show you're
trying to figure out what is it about me
and I want you to hear me say I don't
think it's you man
I don't think it's you and let me tell
you why that's hard to say
because now you're left with this
terrifying well now what
right because it's not doesn't sound
like there's something you can just go
fix
um
I'm gonna say Something's Gonna sound
really callous
and I'm saying this as somebody who's
been through my own hell and back okay
and also has worked with a whole bunch
of people
trauma is very very real I wrote a whole
book about it
and it Cascades through a person's
entire life and through their family
tree if they don't deal with it
and
it's not an excuse to shut your life
down
and so we do not choose the trauma that
happens to us we don't choose the abuse
the marginalization we don't choose
being born in the wrong neighborhood the
wrong color all those things we don't
choose that stuff we do choose what
comes next
and so it sounds like somewhere along
the way either hell visited your wife
either before she was your wife when she
was a little kid whatever
or like you said now I'm starting to
even doubt if that's even true here's
the deal it honestly doesn't matter what
matters is is She gonna look at the
person she committed her life to and say
I hear you
I may not be able to
sleep with you three times a week right
now I get that
but I also understand that I can't go
through my whole life not touching my
husband
I'm gonna go do the work I need to do to
be well
I'm gonna go see a counselor I'm gonna
go sit with a mentor I'm gonna go figure
out why does my body pull away when the
man I love leans in the father of my
kids leans in
right and so that's her work to do and
you can't do it and it sounds like what
you're saying man she doesn't have any
interest at all in doing it
no it doesn't I mean everything that's
important to me just she shuts down I
mean I go to church every every Sunday
with my boys and my dad I've asked her
on multiple occasions you know to come
that I thought was very important and
she just gives me excuses why she
doesn't want to go and I'll give you a
great example you know of one of the
reasons why I wrote wrote In
so recently I had a car accident
um there wasn't that someone cut me off
and and it totaled my truck and I wasn't
hurt you know until I had to go to the
hospital but I was pretty shaken up and
I had pretty bad whiplash
and when I you know called her about the
accident she instead of coming to the
accident she said do I need to come
and so of course I was just like no
you're fine just stay
and then
uh when she got home that evening
you know I told her I said hey you know
I could really use some intimacy you
know my you know my life kind of flashed
before my eyes and you know I really
could use you know you to help me rub my
shoulders and help help me you know to
feel the better and
her exact words were I'm not doing that
because I might make your condition
worse
so that's what kind of like set me over
the top to to write right in can I Can I
Be a Jerk for a second
sure I just want to paint you an
opposite picture here my wife and I buy
a thousand miles are not perfect okay
like I don't want anyone to at all at
all to think that
right
um last year when I was doing um my Wim
Hof breathing exercises in my car doing
85 miles an hour down the highway
um and I passed out and I totaled my car
I was okay I actually drove the car it
went I drove it in and parked it at the
office and had it towed out of here
um but I got here
and I called my wife and I said hey I
totaled the car I'm okay
just wanted to let you know I'm safe if
somebody saw me on the side of the road
or whatever I want you to know I'm okay
and it was about 35 or 45 minutes later
and we lived 30 minutes from here my
wife showed up here
right and she had tears in her eyes and
she said I just need to see you
and she came and gave me a hug and like
but I need you to know that's the other
side
I tell you all that to tell you it's not
a fantasy you're not a needy whiny guy
you're not crazy
but I also want to tell you this
you have to get out of her head and stop
playing the what if I just do this what
if I just do this game
right you have to shift into what I'm
going to call a whole other mode
and it's terrifying dude
you have to ask yourself this is who she
is and this is who she is choosing to be
when it comes to spiritual matters when
it comes to sexuality when it comes to
connectivity and if it hasn't already
it's gonna show up with parenting
decisions and choices
all right so let me say this as clearly
as I can she does not care about you
and I hate saying that
but you you feel that
yes feel it so you have to ask yourself
what am I going to do next
and I can't give you that answer that
might be all right cool unless this is
the life I chose this is the person I
chose I'm gonna settle in here
um this might be you sitting down with a
counselor and begin saying what does
life look like not with her
um this might look like sitting down
with her and saying okay I've reached
I've reached the line here
um and I want to say this when it comes
to infidelity um you may have heard me
say this and so I'll I'll make sure I
clarify myself here
um we talk about infidelity a lot as
like did you have sex with somebody did
you text somebody did you kiss somebody
I think infidelity is a whole is an
infinitely bigger picture
right it's about withholding it's about
denial it's about I'm gonna be about my
life over your life
I'm going to be about my wants and my
needs and I don't care about the the
Covenant I made with you that you're
going to be about we're going to be
about doing life together
and so
um I take a much wider angle when it
comes to infidelity because a lot of
people are just flat out terrible
Marriage Partners they're selfish
they're narcissistic they're jerks
they're they're quasi not physically but
they're quasi-abusive they're just awful
but then they say I didn't sleep with
anybody
yeah dude but you violated the Covenant
of this marriage because when you get
married you say you before me
and she says
you before me and you spend the rest of
your life
in service to one another and y'all are
in service to building something
completely new man and here's the thing
I hate this for you dude and if you were
here I'd give you a hug man
because I I know what I'm telling you is
like a sack of bricks on your shoulder
because you felt it and you felt it and
you felt it but
you gotta ask yourself what do I do next
what do I do next
and I'm gonna recommend you get with
somebody probably a professional or a
minister in your community or it sounds
like your old man and you are pretty
close I would sit down with somebody and
have get some reflection
um and you can go into a lot more detail
with this person
foreign
I'm sorry
I'm sorry that your wife is
um choosing
to
kick dirt in your face
choosing to not connect choosing to
leave you out in the cold
I'm so sorry man and if your wife has a
rebuttal to this if she watches this and
she's like oh you need to know the other
half I'd love her to call in man I'd
love for the other side of the story but
this is the one I got and quite honestly
it breaks my heart but this is not an
uncommon story
where somebody gets married has kids and
they've they're done with him now I can
have my life the one that I wanted with
what I wanted I'm I'm through with this
and I hate that for everybody hate that
for the kids I hate that for for both
both the the both husband and the wife I
hate it for everybody
hate for everybody
thanks for the call my brother I wish I
had some better news or something like
oh yeah just try this sounds like you've
gone to the ends of the Earth man
and you're gonna have to live in that
season of what do I do now and when you
make that decision of what I'm going to
do now you got to be at peace with it
you got to be at peace with it
because living in that gray space man
will kill you
sit with somebody else who tried who you
trust who can reflect back with you you
all make a path for moving forward man
call anytime I can help hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of on your
past change your future man just free of
charge it's a book for you to read it's
about what to do when everything falls
apart and how to pick up the pieces and
take A New Path